President Obama's job speech in which he
proposed an American Jobs Act before the
joint sessions of Congress was an
impressive piece of oratory I thought he
did wonderfully in his presentation but
i think it was a little weak in terms of
the magnitude of the crisis we're going
through he gave the impression that this
act would solve the problems well it
would help some people but it's pretty
limited in the overall impact I believe
in it it's not really up to the
magnitude of the problem we have 14
million unemployed and there's a risk
that the economy is going to sink into
recession so we'll have even more
unemployed and there's a serious risk
that this problem is going to continue
for years what Obama did was brilliant
for a politician he talked about some
tax cuts which is a gift to the people
who are listening and some expenditure
programs and then he left to another day
to talk about how they would be financed
but clearly because of the debt Control
Act which he signed August to he can't
raise expenditures in fact there's a
super committee that has to cut
expenditures further so the net effect
is still going to be to reduce stimulus
so a certain things they sound very good
and I guess they argue for example he
proposed that people who hire some or
companies that hire someone who had been
unemployed for more than six months
would get a special tax break great but
they're going to have to raise taxes
somewhere else and who's that going to
hit so it's not a dramatic improvement
President Obama did talk about tax
increases for the rich and for closing
off corporate loopholes but those are
the aspects of his act that are least
likely to happen the more likely thing
to happen I suppose
will be a payroll tax cut but there will
be something else that offsets that
maybe cut back in some government
expenditure Medicare or something like
that which will offset that there is
some stimulus in this pack but it's
limited so the President's speech to a
joint session of Congress on the night
of September 8th was both a marker of
how severe the jobs crisis is and of how
significant the president's political
troubles are right now he really felt
like he had to take the reins put out a
bold vision a very strong plan and
challenge Congress to act on it and the
plan is large i mean it's 450 billion
dollars in terms of the amount of money
that's going to be spent in a single
year where it to where it to happen
that's it as large as any year of the
stimulus bill that the president pushed
for in 2009 but given the reaction to
that bill now with members of Congress
from the republican party basically
saying the stimulus bill failed we know
that the president faces a very tough
road in Congress so the the real
challenge for him is to create both
public pressure and political pressure
in Congress to really get this this this
bill passed and so the question we
shouldn't we should be asking isn't is
this the ideal jobs bill I can think of
lots of ways in which it could be
designed better i think it probably
needs to be bigger given the scale of
the jobs crisis we're facing right now i
think that it the payroll tax holiday
for employers is probably not going to
have a big effect i would put more into
infrastructure but the question we
should be asking isn't is this big
enough the question we should be asking
is how is the present going to get
something on this scale done and the
only way that's going to happen is if he
pushes aggressively in congress and
takes his message to the American people
and to me the the real puzzle for
understanding what's going on now is
that consistently for the last few years
Americans have been saying unemployment
the jobs crisis is a higher priority
than deficit reduction but all we've
heard about is deficit reduction you
know the president gave a nod to deficit
reduction by saying he was going to pay
for this bill in the future and if he
pays for it too quickly we could really
see ourselves you know robbing Peter to
pay Paul in the sense that we could
see the money pulled out of the economy
when it's still very fragile we don't
just face the risk of a double-dip
recession we faced a probability or at
least a possibility of serious economic
malaise over a long period of time so
the president really needs to to keep
his eye on the ball of doing something
now immediately and pushing the serious
deficit reduction into the future
particularly through cutting healthcare
costs but you know Americans have been
saying jobs is the priority and Congress
has been acting as if the deficit which
is a serious problem but a long-term
problem should come first so at least
we're now having a real discussion about
jobs and both parties are going to be
pressed to offer something in the run-up
to the 2012 election